so
[Music]
absolute spirit as pictured in pure
essence is not indeed abstract pure
essence for abstract essence has sunk to
the level of being merely an element
just because it is only a moment in the
life of spirit but the representation of
spirit in this element is charged with
the same defective form which essence as
such has
essence is an abstraction and is
therefore the negation of its simple
unitary nature is another
similarly spirit in the element of
essence is the form of simple oneness
which therefore is equally essentially
and othering of itself or what is the
same thing
the relation of the eternal being to its
being for self is the immediately simple
one of pure thought
in this simple beholding of itself in
the other the otherness is therefore not
posited as such it is the difference
which in pure thought is immediately no
difference
a loving recognition in which the two
sides as regards their essence do not
stand in an antithetical relation to
each other
spirit that is expressed in the element
of pure thought is itself essentially
this to be not merely in its element but
to be actual spirit for its notion
lies otherness itself that is the
supersession of the pure notion that is
only thought
paragraph
772 is rather short as is the paragraph
immediately following it and it seems
very abstract and metaphysical and what
is going on here
but this is a very important
not so much turning point as in
development that's going to feed into
what's going to be happening in
paragraphs yet to come and which is
showing us a kind of culmination of
where the previous paragraphs have been
leading us we're trying to make sense
out of and there's a couple different
ways to
conceptualize this
essence or spirit in the element of
essence or
eternal being or essence you're going to
notice that if you look at the german
for
this
section
lots and lots of vasin coming up right
and you can translate vase and as
essence you can also translate it as
being understanding that we're talking
about essential being right and so you
know eternal being the god that we're
seeking out in religion which is also
spirit okay that all makes a lot of
sense
and there's some really interesting
stuff
going on here that has to do with
you could call it a
very central hegelian
movement or idea that pervades not just
the phenomenology but his work more
generally the relationship between
whatever is on
one side we can call itself if we want
to although you know here it's not being
talked about so much in terms of
self and more in terms of unity
and essence spirit eternal being
and
on the other hand
it's
it's other right there's a lot of other
vocabulary
here an andres right um
uh we've got
sort of a
self in the other in and we've got being
other on design right so there's a lot
going on here in terms of alterity
or
otherness and there's going to be a
really interesting
is it reconciliation at this point
maybe not but certainly
loving recognition
of
the other which is at the same time
one's own other so a lot being said
there let's begin at the beginning
he tells us that
absolute spirit which is what we've been
trying to get our hands on or get our
heads around for the last several
paragraphs as pictured now this is a
very important
we've been talking a lot about
forstellum throughout the religion
section and particularly in the
paragraphs that lead up to this one
particularly in the last paragraph where
it's the foreshadowing the picture
thinking or representation
of the community and there's an
inadequacy
to for stellangen uh the plural of of
foreshadowing right
there's there's a
problematic status to it it separates
things out that aren't truly
separate and which should be realized as
as connected together and this happens
quite a bit in religion with the
believer
god you know prime example of this is
the unhappy consciousness that we've
referenced a number of times
in here but that also comes up in terms
of the conflict between you know that's
discussed in the spirit section the
laws of the city the laws of the gods
you know different conceptions of what
really matters
and you know we can multiply instances
so
absolute spirit is being pictured for
gestalt right
and it's being pictured
as he says
in pure essence in uh raina vezin right
and
he says it's not indeed
abstract pure essence
well that's an interesting
distinction to make there isn't it
distinction will come up a little bit
later as well
so absolute spirit that is being
pictured or being represented being
understood
imaginatively even
we could use the word conceptually
provided we're not using it in a
hegelian way
the way that
people have typically understood
the absolute spirit
and it's not going to be something
completely abstract
and yet
it certainly appears to be abstract
doesn't it
i mean a lot of what's going on in the
rest of this paragraph
is about the
abstraction
of this
absolute spirit as pure essence now why
abstract essence has sunk to the level
has has
fallen has
gone from a higher state to a lower
state
sunk to the level of merely being an
element
just because it is only a
moment
in spirit or as miller is going to in
you know interpolate the life of
spirit so we've got spirit
which is what we're trying to understand
here
which is also what we're involved in and
what all the human beings
before us who were engaged in religion
we're trying to make sense of as well
and so there's a you know circularity or
reflexivity here
so
we're trying to
make sense of this and the abstraction
of it becomes just a moment or an
element now whenever we hear these terms
moment or element
there's a bigger picture right there's
something larger
going on that something can be a moment
within that's one part of what it means
to be a moment
element kind of kind of similar as well
what else is involved there
and this kind of prefigures what this
whole dialectical exposition of
essence being to
its other
well
um
things are connected with each other
you don't have just isolated
moments
i mean you can't isolate them out if you
want to that's certainly possible to do
that's what
in fact for stellang representation or
also jumping ahead a little bit
darstellum kind of does
but that's not yet where we want to be
in terms of as we see in the end of the
paragraph the notion or the concept that
begith right
it is actually you could say the measure
of an inadequate
concept
we should actually jump ahead to this
final thing right he says uh
spirit that is expressed in the element
of pure thought is it is itself
essentially this to be not merely in
this element to be actual spirit we'll
talk about that in a moment here's the
the key that we want for in its notion
lies otherness itself in its begith in
the begin of actual spirit or spirit
that is expressed in the element of pure
thought
is otherness and what is that the
supersession of the pure
notion that is only thought the pure
notion
the pure the haina begith is not truly
notion
it's thought it's
just thought
and it's not yet actuality
we'll come back to that in a moment but
it gives you an idea about
the inadequacy of representation
so he goes on
the representation now he's using a
different term
if you're reading the miller translation
you might
not realize that hegel here has moved
from
you know for gestalt
to
darsh dalong
both are stellan words right
we haven't seen darsh delong come up
since around the 620s
in this it actually was being used quite
a bit earlier on in the religion section
you know from the late 500s into the
early 600s but it hasn't popped up again
until now you say what's the difference
between foreshadowing and darshan well
you know there's more of a connotation
of the putting it there
i mean fortunately literally putting it
putting it in front of us
or something you could say in place of
another we think of a semiotic relation
to it to some degree right darshtelling
has more of a
uh
spatial
um sense to it right but it's pretty
closely connected so the representation
of spirit in this element what element
the element of abstract pure essence
is charged with the same defect the same
lack mongol in german a
void of form
which essence as such has
essence has a
lack of form
well it does at this point
right
and this is kind of interesting this is
a little bit of a digression here
we're often trying to grasp
what is essential what what is the most
important thing that's going on here
what can we bullet point out what can we
you know put into a single sentence to
encapsulate this i mean miller actually
does something like that in the back of
his own
work right you can see here there's all
these little paragraph numbers then he
gives you like one or two sentences
about what's happening a summary in that
paragraph
well
that's not the full dialectic right nor
should it be taken as a substitute for
the dialectic
and you know
there's a problem there when we think
that we've grasped the essentials
sometimes we haven't actually grasped
the essential one of the good things
about dialectical philosophy is it can
unpack for us
what's actually going on in the
background what's missing
what yet still has to come what is
desirable
what uh we have to start looking for
anyway look let's go up don't want to
belabor this point too much
so he says that um
essence
is an abstraction
and is therefore the negation
of its simple unitary nature it is
an other so essence of vason right
is
negation
negative right in in
german so it's the
you know if we want to be a little bit
more literal it's the negative
um because it's abstract right and it's
uh the negative of its
simple unitary nature which is just
einheit here right
and what is this going to mean well
there's an otherness involved
it's not
essence is not just
its simple unitary nature it is it's
simple unitary nature but it's also its
negation so
essence is more complicated
than we
think it to be it's not just a simple
thing
he goes on and he
adds to this picture similarly spirit in
the element of essence right so spirit
in the
element of this represented
you know darsh darge stealth as
essence as simple essence
spirit in this element of essence is
the form
i thought it i thought we were lacking
form here well now we have a form that's
being restored but what is it the form
of simple oneness and so we had einheit
now we have
ein falcon
einheit
so
the form of simple oneness we've got
unitary nature unity einheit oneness
and it's
simple it's
one fold literally and now
you know that's kind of funny to think
about if we often contrast the manifold
to the simple right the manifold has got
many different folds monty faulty kite
ein [ __ ] right um
there's only
one way that this is a form of it's you
sort of like
unity that has been made more unified
unity that has been made more simple or
we could say simplicity that is even
more simple
and why because there's this intricate
connection between essence and spirit
which is being uh depicted is being put
forth in the element of essence okay so
we've got two things now
that are connected together and they
both have this othering going on
what else then he says what is the same
thing okay this tells us right here
what's happening with these is also
what's happening with this third one
uh what is it so
the relation of the eternal being to its
being for self
so the eternal being god right
the relation the z
to its being for self it's fuzzy design
well this is important because now we
have a kind of agency
and
you know reflection going on
within the the eternal being and he says
this is the immediately simple one
again einheit right of pure thought and
immediately simple um it's actually
hyphenated in the german when mitchell
einfach right so same vocabulary coming
up in all of these of pure thought
now what happens with all of these
so essence
is an other anandrus
right
spirit
uh
he says
therefore is equally essentially
right
so
spirit which is in the element of
essence is essentially
an othering
anders vasen
of itself
a
becoming other
of itself so now we've got is another
becomes an other and then he says the
the relation of the eternal being to its
being for self immediate simple of pure
thought and what do we have going on
here now
in this simple beholding and shawn right
of itself
in the other the otherness is therefore
not posited
as such nicked alzoka gazettes right
so we've got the being other
uh happening here anders sein
now we've got like otherness or
alternative
becoming other the othering of the self
uh the being other and beholding of its
self in the other this is a very complex
and rich
uh discussion of alterity isn't it
here's where we get to the really
interesting
meaty stuff
in this simple beholding of itself and
the other the otherness is therefore not
positive as such it's not put there
gazettes
it is the difference
right a division
which in pure thought
in pure thought
the pure thought of the eternal being
is immediately
no difference kind of untashid
and what is this hegel now
changes to a very very different
vocabulary
one that's
you know so rich in implications
it is a loving
recognition
an
love is being invoked here now right
anir cannon this is something that from
the the very
beginning
and especially you know made explicit in
the self-consciousness section this is
what we're looking for
on air cannon right mutual uh
recognition or
uh acknowledgement and this isn't a this
is a recognition
of love
through love by love with love right the
the dare there could mean a lot of
different things a loving recognition in
which the two sides as regards their
essence their vase and again
do not stand in an antithetical
relation with each other as a matter of
fact
antithetical is not the right word to
use there
they're not even opposed to be
antithesis to each other is a little bit
stronger than mere opposition
and gagan gazettes is the german word
that's being used there they are not ant
gagan gazettes they are not being
opposed to each other in this loving
recognition
and then he says something and the stuff
that we talked about just a little bit
earlier
this is you know
really a capstone here spirit that is
expressed in the element of pure thought
so we might say oh
element of pure thought really abstract
there hegel
well yes and no
is itself essentially this again
vaseline right
to be not merely in this element
to be pure thought
pure thought requires that we go beyond
pure thought we go into an otherness to
grasp that
concretely means what
to be actual spirit via clicker
to be
real
to
attain reality
right
and this he says
to be actual spirit for in its notion in
its begith
lies otherness itself once again the
alternative that we cannot avoid and
what is this he says well
the supersession of the pure notion that
is only thought the supersession the auf
haben this is the term that we see over
and over again in the phenomenology
right the supersession of a notion that
is not yet a full
notion this is how notions develop the
notion in this case of
god
of the god that we've been seeking in
religion
so there's an awful lot going on here in
this short paragraph
the element of pure thought because it
is an abstract element is itself rather
the other of its simple unitary nature
and therefore passes over into the
element proper to picture thinking
the element in which the moments of the
pure notion obtain a substantial
existence relatively to one another
and also our subjects which do not
possess for a third the indifference
towards each other of mere being
but being reflected into themselves
spontaneously part asunder and also
place themselves over against each other
paragraph
773 is a
follow-up to the paragraph that we've
just looked at paragraph 772 there is a
lot of the same terminology
and language and ideas being worked out
in here but we've got a few other
important developments that are going to
lead us now into being able to
go more concrete more substantial in the
paragraphs about to come
so he starts by talking about this
element of pure thought which we
saw that absolute spirit is going to be
articulating itself
in and that this you know element of
pure thought cannot just be pure thought
or it becomes it sort of sinks to the
level of an abstraction and we saw a lot
of discussion in the previous paragraph
about this simple
unitary nature or simplicity or oneness
einheit in this case right and we had
einfach ein height
so you know this this is something
important to this element of pure
thought he says this element of pure
thought because it is an abstract
element and now we get something really
interesting
we've already talked about otherness
just in the previous paragraph and now
otherness is being talked about in
yet another way right the element of
pure thought
is itself because it's abstract
uh the other
of its simple unitary nature so it
cannot be
simple it already introduces alternative
within itself as we saw in the previous
paragraph and now it passes over
git uber right uber gain transforms into
lapses into these are all ways that we
could think of this and it it transforms
into another
element so we've got an element
transforming or passing
over into an element what is the element
here
the element proper to picture thinking
right the
agent leak element the the one that
belongs to representation
and
you know what would we say about that
well isn't that just representation
itself yes representation always turns
out to be more complex there's more
going on than we thought and
interestingly
in this
something
is going to be able to happen so he says
the element proper to picture thinking
is the element
in which the moments of the pure notion
the
nubif right what we concluded
the
last
paragraph with with a
supersession or
you know going beyond and incorporating
the pure notion that is only thought and
this is leading us to
actual spirit spirit in
to pre-figure a little bit spirit in the
world right spirit of a world
so he goes on and he says
these moments of the pure notion
which would otherwise just be merely
abstract
they obtain they they get something it
halt him and what do they get
well they get two things and they also
aren't something
else in the description
they gain substantial existence
design
so
you know the dozen of substances this is
just a a cognate the english to the
german substantial
zen right
so
in the pure notion these moments are now
gaining
substantial existence but now this is
very important because in picture
thinking there's a risk of each of them
getting a substantial existence that's
disconnected from the other
but in this case it's relatively
to each other
right
so
what is the term there gagan ananda
so
you know
in the previous paragraph we saw that
there was a distinction an untrashed
that was you know or division that was
no longer being divided in pure thought
we saw that there was an overcoming of
antithesis or rather opposition
in this case we have opposition and in a
kind of strong sense gaganinder right
which makes us think of gaganza it's
contradiction
so
we have a restoration within
the element proper to picture thinking
of what the pure notion can provide us
with which is moments
that actually can be opposed to each
other and opposed to each other in
if we want to piggyback off of this
substantiality of existence in
substantial ways
it goes further
right he also says that they are
subjects
and here's something you know here's the
what's being left out which do not
possess for a third the indifference
glycogen the
you know it's just as good everything is
just fine
uh
they're not all on the same level
necessarily for a third the indifference
towards each other of mere being
but
instead
being
reflected into themselves in zeke
reflect right um
what happens with this reflection
into themselves they spontaneous
spontaneously
part asunder
but also and now notice once again
place themselves over against each other
and gegen schtelen
now this is a really interesting term to
use right and gagan right sort of like
the
gegenninder the opposition is now back
stalin
in the previous paragraph we had
stellen
for stellang right and we had darstellen
now and gegenstellen
you know it's not representation anymore
it's rather placing themselves in
relation to each other and opposed to
each other right so there's something
really
quite cool happening here you could say
through this this passing over of the
element of uh pure thought into the
element proper to picture thinking it
allows the pure notion to
have this differentiation within itself
and a differentiation that isn't just
like well there's abstract ideas that
can be distinguished from each other no
we're getting something more concrete
here something more vercleak is
something more
actually
you